hey everybody sorry for the delay I
didn't I need to see that it is started
today I have a different camera so it's
still a built-in camera but it's on my
second day monitors so the angles a
little bit different so I'm gonna have
to get used to looking over here but
it'll probably work out because this is
the monitor that I have the code on so
I'm normally looking over here anyway so
we'll give it a shot and see if this one
works better so now you get to see the
other side of my office
you see there's my whiteboard that I
never use and there's my door I can
finally see people walking by and today
we're gonna work on the footer which is
I think I said that yesterday so not too
much of a surprise but I want to work on
the footer because that's the next part
in the in the structure so yesterday we
had said we're using materialised
framework and that framework you have
within your body you have a a header and
then as a sibling component a sibling
element you have main and then as the
final sibling you have footer so we've
already done the header we have main
there but there's nothing really in it
yet at least nothing visible there's
some structure so just some add some
elements and there's some divs and
things and then we have a footer already
but it's not it's not implemented the
way we want it so I want to get that
finished so the footer looks like it's
going to look and then we can start like
piece by piece adding things and two
main all right let me check the live
chat just to say hi before we start
okay we do have a question about the
what is p3 b6 and I'm Barry to answer
that but I want to say that just in case
there's anybody else wondering about it
they can't see the live shot at the end
of the titles of the videos I've been
putting like for instance today p3 d6
that just means project three day six
just wanted to make it a little bit
shorter so that the title of the video
wasn't really long in the description I
actually write out the whole thing
project three day six so if you see that
that's what it means it's just kind of
way to keep things organized for
everyone let me get this off of the
screen this was still for the other
project so for project two today I added
yesterday I added in analytics with
react GA and then today I added in some
some click some event tracking to track
all of our downloads all the logo
downloads and the letterhead downloads
so that that'll show up as events in
Google Analytics occasionally I need to
report the stats on how many people are
actually downloading things from that
resource center so that the head of my
department can go and to people higher
up and justify the time spent on on the
Resource Center
see so let's move I make sure I get my
windows I think my windows are still the
same as they were to the a so we'll be
working in here and you saw our dev
tools for that and then here's our
here's our cup alright great so let me
see I said I was gonna check the live
shot and I didn't get very far
hey everyone a lot of people saying hi
okay so we have a question I'll take
this question first and then we'll get
started on the code code Chandra says hi
Jessie I'm unable to create a footer
which will be always placed on the
bottom of the page
why is it happening so you could let me
see there are already some responses so
let me see what let's see whatever
response getting resized okay it looks
like I'm not sure how to pronounce it
but it's a okole let me know if that's
the wrong pronunciation but okole is
gonna send a code snippet so so Shandra
let me know if that code snippet doesn't
work and maybe I can help
or maybe at the end during the question
and answer I could try to help a little
bit or if you need more help maybe
message me on Twitter we're gonna see
with the footer today it is always gonna
stay on the bottom but I'm gonna use
materialized framework and it's gonna do
that automatically we could take a look
though at the CSS when we do it and then
you know maybe you'll get an idea about
how they do it and that framework and
maybe you can apply that so you know
it's is the is the video synced up to my
to my face I there's like a slight delay
and it's weird and I wonder that is
really weird to see that I'm gonna try
my best not to look at myself so I'm
gonna move this over to the other screen
that I don't normally look at because
it's freaking me out
I'm talking and then afterwards I see my
my mouth move Darrow asked if I'm using
c-sharp yeah we are using some c-sharp
so we'll see what we don't
basically we're editing these these
templates so we're not really getting in
a lot into directly into the c-sharp
stuff but occasionally we are gonna edit
some some of the c-sharp thing so you
can see like you know we have some stuff
here that we will be working with but
for right now we're gonna go to we're
here at the bottom of this main test
master let me okay so for some reason
Google thought that I was talking to it
on my phone I just looked over and I've
been having a conversation with the
Google assistant inadvertently uh-huh
okay so here's our footer section so
it's it's not bad we already have it you
know as a footer element which is good
that's that's what we want for
materialized so it's likely that we do
have some C where did our main go okay
so right now the footer is inside of
main so it may be that some of the
styles for materialized are getting
applied because we have this this footer
element but since it's within main I
doubt it's it's knowing exactly what
it's supposed to do so I'm gonna take
this out and I'm gonna take this out as
well this comment and then let's put in
our footer here and I'm gonna just save
that and quickly check before we get
started I want to see if that did
anything it shouldn't I don't expect it
to have any big impact okay great I do
want to check to see if any of the
materialized styles are already being
applied and you know what's if
anything's getting overridden let's see
so we do have materialized basically
the only thing that's supplied now is
display:block and then these are some of
the custom styles that's making that
border
okay so far it doesn't look like we have
anything anything that is being
overridden I think it's your lives the
font size the font size may be different
trying to find where the original is
it's probably up somewhere and I just
missed it but it looks it looks pretty
good so so far so good hopefully we
don't have a lot of conflicts between
the styles but not bad we do have some
weird stuff going on down here and
hopefully this will work itself out as
we we take out this content or at least
reformat this content with our are
calling classes that we're going to use
and materialize so I'm not gonna worry
about this yet if we reformat everything
and we're still having this problem then
we'll dig a little bit deeper and try to
figure it out okay so right now we have
which is actually it's nice that it's
commented like this are left call and
it'll call them right : but what we need
to do is we need to keep these because
this the contents being brought in here
but we need to remove this article and
I'm actually not sure why they chose to
use article for that I mean can you all
think of any reason why article would be
the proper element for for these
sections in the footer I don't know that
seems it seems a little little odd I
just looked at the live chat and john b
says without my glasses I don't see
sharp so like get it it's because we're
doing c-sharp because I thought it was
funny
okay so let's do that let's get rid of
these articles or at least change them
oh well I'm yawning already sorry about
that
okay
so I like this is in the section I might
actually get rid of the section I don't
think we really need a section inside I
know that they're doing it they're
splitting out that bottom part of the
footer but that's not really how I do
the the footers with materialised so
let's take a look let's take a look at
how we're doing the footer here and we
can just copy it and bring it over that
that'll probably be the easiest way to
do it
whoa okay I actually don't want I don't
want the social media icons in the
footer because we have them in the
header and that's in that sticky so the
user will always have it there we don't
need them down there so I'm gonna take
that up and that's gonna make things a
lot easier
well we'll copy it all first and then
then we'll take it out
all right let's copy that and let's put
it below for now and we'll take we don't
need we have the copyright for the icons
in the top nav already so we don't need
that where's our social okay so
everything here in our social div will
get rid of
a-and I was using inline SVG's for that
see that's why there's all these these
numbers if you haven't used those before
I really like them for things like
social media icons because you can see
that the path for the SVG is not really
that long I mean if you there are some
SPG's that are like pages long but in
this case it's not it's not really a big
deal to just pop that in there you don't
have to load something else into the
page so I like to use them whenever I
can
alright so you can see now instead of
having a section I just have this this
class footer copyright container so what
we're gonna do for the copyright date I
am gonna change it to 2017 but if you
remember in our our JavaScript file our
custom javascript file that we brought
over from our demo site it had a little
function in there that kept this up to
date so we don't have to worry about
bringing that in so I'm gonna leave that
there I like this so I'm not gonna worry
if we look here about this part I don't
think I'm gonna worry about that we
might try to bring some of that in but
the things that are gonna go down there
are not likely to change you know this
is is probably never going to change so
we do need to worry about you know some
of these links but I'm not exactly sure
where I want them because these are a
lot of links we'll see I haven't decided
yet exactly what I want to do with that
so for now I'm gonna leave it out to
relieve that just as is the universities
address and phone number and email it's
not likely to change so I'm gonna keep
it how I have it because I'm using you
know this the schema so I doubt that
that's in use right now we can double
check it
no these are just P tags so I mean it
actually they do have it in an address
so it's not it's not too bad but we
could I guess we could add the slogan if
we really want to so for now we're not
going to bring in this what is it the
left we're not gonna bring that in
either but we are gonna bring in these
two it's possible that the wording and
the links in here would change we are
working on a new application so I'm
doing the front-end for that in terms of
basically just making it look nicer so
when that launches we will need to
change this link so I'd like this to be
changeable from the CMS okay all right
so let's pull that in going the wrong
way all right I forgot to start my timer
again this is two days in a row all
right I'm just gonna keep a look let's
see what time it is on the floor all
right I'm gonna set a 10-minute timer
then and I have this let's throw this in
here so we can see it when we go to
check that okay after the 10 minutes is
up then I'll take a five-minute break
and I'll answer some questions let's see
let's grab this
like to see the structure so this is
what comes out so we have an H to a P
tag and then a class that's about I
don't like that I I would really love to
find the template for the buttons so
that we could just automatically have
the materialized style buttons apply we
could put in the right classes for now
I'm not going to worry about it but I
think that would be nice we you know we
could always add some classes to our CSS
and just use whatever whatever they have
here in terms of classes but I think it
would be it would be nicer if we could
just find this template and then have it
apply you know throughout and not not
have to you know mess with modifying the
classes in materialise okay
not really sure I would go with h2s here
but we'll just we'll leave it at that
for now
okay so we're keeping that address
see why am i I guess I only had alright
I see
I had the logo of large size and then
the address here okay how are the make
sense alright so let's keep
maybe we can change this structure a bit
let's I get I guess we'll keep this
structure for now in terms of just three
columns logo and address over here okay
so we're gonna change this to and now
this logo is not gonna show up
immediately I didn't bring this over yet
so we're definitely getting an error on
this at first or so changes to an M for
the column classes and materialise are
based on 12 so you can see on small
screen so as 12 this means it'll be full
width on 12 or on small screens on
medium screens and up it will take up
four of the twelve columns which means
they'll end up being three columns right
so 12 divided by 4 is 3 so that's how we
handle our columns let's grab this
let's try to put this on top of here and
just see how how large that becomes and
I may have to change this too to match
the h2s that are gonna come in I may be
able I'm not sure how those h2s are
getting in there if there's like a
WYSIWYG editor and there's manually been
h2s put in there or if it's a template
that pulls the title and of that piece
of content and puts it in h2 so we may
be able to change that and just make
them all h5 we'll see all right so now
that that's out I'm gonna take this and
all within the same row this is not
giving me the corresponding div I don't
like all right okay so let's put two
more columns there and now we can take
our content
so use this content and put this in here
and we'll take a right column content
and put it in here in our last call on
and I want to completely get rid of
everything in this footer actually I
want to see
I can't want to see what's in there
right now so let's let's put this in
here it's gonna look really weird at
first but I just want to see how it how
it comes out I see what we can do with
it save that and then let's let's check
it out there we go
I'm gonna keep an eye on that timer whoa
okay
so it's looking for this content block
this footer Left content block that we
got rid of so let's go into that c-sharp
file and see if see if it's in there
yeah footer left okay
let's get rid of that so we'll just
comment it out for now and see if that
fixes it
mmm
okay not yet
there we go
that should be it I don't think it's
referenced anywhere else
all right
whoa-ha-ha very different okay so this
is the default color
I wonder what size image I'm loading in
there that keeps taking quite a while
off to double-check on that okay so
definitely need some need some work
right we don't want the shadows here or
this font so definitely don't want this
color these buttons don't aren't how we
want then let's check out down here down
here we didn't have any of the any of
these other links that I thought we
would get you can see here we're getting
all of this but that did not show up
let's see
interesting okay well that explains why
it was getting styled differently before
is that it's inside of an Ave okay still
not sure why it's not
okay so the timer's probably almost you
can see things are looking a little bit
weird right now
we'll just have to fix up the Styles a
bit and figure out what where those
links were coming in at the ones way at
the bottom of the footer and see if we
can get them back preferably in a format
that's not in a nav I'm gonna take a
five minute break to answer questions
check out the live chat and then we'll
do another Pomodoro session we do at
least one more session and then we'll
see what time it is
if yeah we'll do one more session for
sure and we'll just see how it's going I
kind of think what we can get this to
the point where it looks pretty good
with one more
okay a spar spar willsez so that's a
copy and paste SVG yes yeah for sure
yeah you just copy it
the SVG's put them right in there in
that case for those social media icons I
got them from someone's code pen which I
did a tribute where I got them that it's
not in this file it's in the other file
so I have the big they had a big thing
in their code pen saying if you use
these icons make sure you include this
you know in your in your code so I did
andreas Larsen and I think thank you
that's who did it so anyway they're
really nice very small SVG's for other
icons for my material icons I just go to
the material icon website look up the
one I want and then you can get them
either as a ping or an SVG or a font
icon and I just grabbed the SVG it's a
it's a similar thing really small SVG
snippet you just put them right in the
project
all right Blake Thomas says does anybody
here know PHP I know a little bit of PHP
so I'm not really sure if you have a
question about it about something
specific in PHP you could let me know
I'll do my best but I'm not really
confident that I could give you a great
answer because I don't use PHP
frequently how Rowan says was busy last
week looks like things have changed says
whoa vs code live cam view asp.net yeah
it's very deep if you've been gone for
two weeks things have changed so to two
weeks ago we were using atom and react
and we had no live live video so I know
they're gone so we had no live video of
my face definitely a little bit
different now
hopefully the next project is back to
react I'd like to get back to react this
is cool it's kind of fun to do something
different but I don't know that this is
really expanding my my skills and in a
way that is the most efficient way to
get better you know trying to learn some
legacy stuff that I don't know yeah the
odds of me having to use this even at
this job in the future a really small
let alone at another job but a lot of
the basic stuff like the HTML CSS that's
the same everywhere so it's not like I'm
not you're practicing my skills at all
cool John Hansen says SVG SVG Oh on
github is a great node tool that will
make an SVG SVG files small enough to
paste in line awesome
I'm just looking for questions here
okay so blank who asked about PHP
earlier says I'm trying to set up a
wordpress website for a nonprofit but
the WP style guide slash template they
have has an error I can't figure it out
okay okay so it looks like John B's
gonna work on that error let us know
okay it looks it looks like Blake just
pulled it up the website and now it
works so it didn't work this morning and
not work so that's cool when that
happens I mean you always wish you knew
what the problem was but if it works and
it keeps working then that's that's
awesome okay so I got to the bottom of
the live chat and the timer just went
off so let's start this up again let's
see if we can get this footer finished
and one more Pomodoro session
alright first things first I want to
find out where these links are the
styling stuff is gonna be no problem the
links I'm not really sure what's going
on with that so let's tackle that one
first so I think I'll bring up so this
is our main test master I'm going to
bring up the normal main dot master and
go down to the footer since we took out
a lot of stuff from the footer I want to
see how it was initially oh I see now it
looks like did we have it looks like we
had multiple things here in this this
copyright section and I did not grab
them I just took them all out so which
one did I grab let's see
I grabbed this one and I don't think
this has anything we need so I'm gonna
take that out and instead I'm gonna
bring in alright we don't need the
social icons this looks like what we
need this footer menu so like I said
already I don't like that this is a nav
we'll see what it looks like I don't
think it's gonna look good we may just
have to hard code those links in and if
they need changed I'll just have to do
it I don't think that's really a big
deal those links if they're changed at
all it's once a year I'm fine with
taking five minutes once a year to come
in here and change that
oh my god
all right so let's see hey Kix I expect
this to look terrible
whoa okay I took out the footer
copyright so that's why we're getting
that error again let's take this outside
accidentally edit it because that's that
was the live site so let's take out this
footer copyright and I'm just gonna
remove it up here
yeah we should be good
okay All Right see ya we're getting
we're getting this in here we're also
getting no we're getting that did I
leave something in that I should not
have maybe I need to put in the the HTML
code for copyright
so I'm looking that up on looking that
up on my other screen it's actually
really really nice it came up right in
Google search I don't even have to click
anything it was just right at the top so
let's make sure that that was the
problem and that it fixed it yep that
fixed it okay cool so we have the
correct copyright symbol now we have
these I guess we have two options option
one is we just add in some really
specific styles to make this look how we
want it to look option two we hard-code
them let's just check out what's going
on with the styles quickly in dev tools
see how hard it would be
I think the fastest thing at this point
would be to hard-code them but we'll
need our nav let's take out some of the
stuff from the nav it's gonna mess up
our top nav briefly but
okay
yeah I guess we could take all that out
now I'm just I'm gonna hard coat it
they said it's only for links you know
directions won't change privacy policy
probably won't change contact us won't
change the non-discrimination statement
I don't the privacy policy and
non-discrimination statement are the
only things that might change I'm not
really sure if these have to change here
to here or not so let's see how we want
to do this probably I think what I'd
like to do is have the copyright on this
side and then have the links over here
at the bottom then when the screen gets
smaller we may we just maybe stack them
on small screens yeah yeah we'll stack
them
yeah it's really think I will do this
I'd rather have the links on top let's
see here so here so I want to do this
we're gonna take this out and we'll add
inside this container we're gonna put
this inside I'm gonna make a row did
first then class and then row so this is
this is how you set things up and
materialize and I really need to get
some plugins here for Visual Studio code
how's it look used to Adam just like
automatically writing most of my code
for me then we need two columns
it's going to be s12 m6
so two columns
let's take this and we'll put that in
the first column and then within our
second column we're going to need we'll
just do a ul that'd be the best way yeah
we'll do a ul
and we had four lengths only for allies
okay so for now I'm just gonna put the
names I don't remember what they were
contact us privacy policy directions
I mean it's moving it
okay
now let's say that see what it looks
like
definitely gonna have you know work on
this this ul but at least we'll get an
idea of what what we have oops
I'm gonna do it over to the other screen
okay
all right so we want want
that's our
okay I didn't realize this until now so
Rho is some you know we get that class
with materialized but it looks like the
site had already had some styles that
were on row here so was giving it a
width of 100% and a max width of 960
pixels so I do not want that you see
that was our problem here so this is
closer to what we're gonna want and so
you don't really need that let's let's
make sure we we override these in our
and a new new design so let's just
I guess we can set with two Auto and Max
with we do max with none is that valid
yeah it looks like that works
okay so let's find that now and make
those changes so Jess
and up here for right now we don't I'm
not very organized
all right see you just want to try to
cancel out what was already being done
let's refresh
oops let's see what we have going on
with a row
okay great so that's their awesome
so now we can we can put our our styles
here
we already have some footer styles down
here so let's just put it put it down
here with that
what do we have this in footer I guess
we don't I want to be really specific so
let's go I want to be specific just in
case we put we ever put a list up in
that top portion of the footer I want it
I don't want to have to worry about that
list being horizontal instead of
vertical which is what you would
normally think when you did a list so
that's why I want to be specific and
make sure this is in footer
copyright so what do we have we just put
a float on it for now float and I think
I had said float left but I think we
should float it right
okay all right great
actually this is in a different order
that
okay
if I float it left we do get it in the
right order at least
let's see how that looks
all right let's see what right looks
like again
I don't know that I could even sell the
difference
oh yeah it looks like it really would
have only moved slightly over one way to
the other so if we had it to the right
or to the left so I think it doesn't
matter here if it would have been a more
significant shift over to the right I
would have floated right and then just
changed the order so it ended up being
in the right order but for now I think
left will be fine and that will save us
from having to change the order and
right we don't really have see that much
of a shift you can see here you know it
really hasn't shifted too much just a
few pick I mean that's maybe 10 pixels
of a difference okay we didn't need to
add some padding here so let's add
padding will add the padding to the left
and that'll that'll help at least not
shift it even more over than we needed
to otherwise I probably would have added
it right whoops
we go eight pixels and mm-hm
let's see how this look we definitely
need this to be white there we go
now we can see it better all right
I'd like that maybe a little bit more
space in here but I'm not I think it's
fine all right for these links at the
footer that most people will never even
see I don't think it's I don't think
it's expected to have you know a lot of
space around here so but looks okay for
now I didn't like the fact that you know
very early on it goes down like this so
what I think I may do and I want to
double-check this now
what I think I may do is change the
column widths so that this has more
space so let's do that now and let's
make this let's see how wide we can get
away with so let's make that a nine
we'll make this a three this might be
too much but we'll give it a shot
yeah yeah I think that's too much as you
could see with you know automatically
this goes on to two lines all right so
let's go for should be fine then we also
want to make sure that we we put in the
rest of that CSS that we had just put in
here so we need a color and then padding
left at 10 pixels
okay I want to check my timer all right
just under four minutes and whoops and I
never changed this back this needs to be
left
oh that actually that that's interesting
so since I changed the column classes
this actually is a much larger shift so
we may have to end up going back to our
padding right or our float right but
what this does give us is that you know
we can come to a much smaller size
without having these wrap you know I
don't we're not gonna be able to have it
so that you know either one rats unless
we go you know that's we stack them
really early on as you can see the other
alternative to is right now these are in
a container we could potentially expand
this out and give them the full width of
the page normally I don't like to do
that I think it looks nicer if we keep
that in line here but in this case we
have a lot to go in here so that's
that's also an option
you see
see what we can do in two minutes here
let's at least get
let's get this this background the right
color at the very least I want to see
what div that is applied to okay the
page page footer okay so it's on the
footer so
and put it right here this should work
background color you know to 1/4 1/2 a
that's the green color
okay definitely don't want this text to
be black and we want to change these
fonts
and you know we would normally have the
logo here as well so this contact would
be down a bit farther and then we'd have
the logo and this now that I look at
this it might make more sense to flip
this around a bit this section looks
shorter than this section we'll have to
see I guess that's not really important
right now you know this could
potentially change also I don't think I
want this centered like I'd rather have
it aligned differently so just some
little things for the most part
everything's working fine now with this
footer we're pulling in this data here
from the CMS and this data here as well
we've hard-coded this and it just needs
a bit of adjustment we do need to make
some decisions about how these what we
want to do whether or not we want them
to wrap onto another line or whether we
just want to have them stack you know
kind of early on I don't know I don't
like to have a really tall copyright
area here but in this case in this case
we might it might actually look better
to just stack them right off the bat you
know we got a lot going on here and then
then we'd be able to give this a little
bit more space yeah maybe I'll do that
so I've got some decisions to make on
this and maybe we'll make them together
tomorrow we'll see how far I get between
now and then okay so my timer went off
and I think - Thomas yeah I think I'm
going to do questions now and
and then we'll finish up after questions
so if anybody is not interested in
sticking around for the questions thank
you for watching and please join us
again sometime if you can't stick around
that would be awesome if you have a
question please put it in the live chat
now and even if you don't have a
question please stick around if you can
and hope to answer some of these
questions alright so I'm gonna try to
scroll up and find where I left off and
I'm just gonna keep going down from
there and I'll get to I'll get to all
the questions today definitely have time
for that
okay I think I found it here
oh okay so John B says if you type in
dot row Visual Studio code will
automatically make it a div for you by
default the s code has Emmet installed
by default oh I did not know that that's
really cool also can do the same for ID
I want to try that out right now and
that'll help me remember it better as
well but let's let's try it out so and
then oh that's so cool
John B that's the that's the tip of the
day okay so if if you use Visual Studio
code try that out I'm trying to think
what else you can do with Emmet can't
you do stuff like with L eyes oh yes you
can
oh man let's try this you know that
didn't work how do you do the u.s. shoot
I thought there was some way that you
could just do you could do it like a
string but anyway that's really cool
and then with the ID - so cool now that
now I'm just playing around here let's
see if I can do okay let's try this
again
in the house very nice
that's really cool thank you thank you
for that that's that's awesome now I'm
gonna have to look I haven't done
anything with Emmet I remember I did
some tutorials with it a long time ago
like the years ago and I don't remember
much now I'm gonna have to check it out
again
okay John B says waited that's where
HTML files may not work for master well
actually so this isn't really an HTML
file but I set it to treat it like an
HTML file so I think that's why it ends
up working
okay and he mentioned you have to press
tab right so when I was doing that I
pressed tab when I was done typing and
that's then it then it did that John
Hanson said don't bring that footer up
on the screen too often the colors are
burning my eyes yeah that was pretty bad
for her little Wow
okay rowan says there's an asp net
helper package cool I will have to try
that
oh is lint I'm not sure I pronounces so
this means I don't know I'm really sorry
zi z Li and I and the za
so sorry I was having trouble
pronouncing that but anyway says to use
flexbox instead of floats john hanson
commented that flexbox won't do much
here since there's a column framework
set up yeah so the column framework
would do what we wanted here pretty much
otherwise I probably would try to use
flexbox in particular I would it would
be cool to use being able to reorder
things on different screen sizes would
be good because I want right I want the
copyright to be on the left in the menu
to be on the right but then on a small
screen size I want him to flip positions
so that the copyright goes on the bottom
right in the second place which normally
is in the first so you can do that
easily with flexbox anyway we'll see I'm
undecided exactly how I'm going to do
that
nobody says thanks for the streaming
you're welcome I appreciate you saying
that okay Shay says any specific design
inspiration for this project beyond the
university style guides style guidelines
no I don't really have I mean it's gonna
be just basically along the style
guidelines but uh so I'll talk a little
bit about kind of what I'm going for
I would like it to be for this middle
section to have large full width
sections of of content
I mean pizza there's gonna be some space
on the sides on on really large screens
you know obviously but right now you can
see it has kind of this split nice
there's all these sections and it split
up into three columns excuse me I just
can't quit yawning sorry to everyone if
I'm making you yawn out there I know
it's contagious but we have this
occasionally it's broken up by things
like this but I want to get rid of all
that and just have you know sections no
no big columns like this so within one
section maybe I'll have some columns
depending on if the content makes sense
to be in columns but I would I would
rather have kind of a progression of
ideas you know some web pages it's
almost like it tells a story about
something as you scroll down right now I
just don't feel that we're we're telling
a story I think that these you know the
sections are in here and could be
flipped around you know the about could
definitely be elsewhere right academics
admissions I mean these
these don't have to be in this order
they could be flipped around I think and
still be be fine these could be in any
order so I'd like to try to have it in
some you know more of an order you know
right here it's gonna probably say apply
and then we have donate here so if
somebody who knows what they want to do
already they're gonna be able to do it
but otherwise once they scroll we're
gonna tell them the story about the
University and once they get to the
bottom then we can give them another
call to action to either apply or donate
or learn more but I want it to be less
words and more targeted more intentional
about what we want users to know right
now there's just so much going on here
if someone just came here for the first
time and knew almost nothing about the
University I think it would just be an
overload of you know what what's this
you know what is it really about on this
page it just seems like there's just so
much so much information it's hard to
pick out what the most important
information is so that's kind of my you
know beyond just the basic design that's
that's my inspiration for just kind of
the flow I wonder if this might be I
guess somewhat of a good visual example
I don't know I think I've shown this
before but this is a sight I did last
year at some point it has it's it's a
little bit different right it's not
it hasn't some of the same elements to
it but this is a like a building
development that the University is doing
so that it's gonna have a hotel with
restaurants and things so thanks for the
students to do things for visitors to
the University to be able to stay there
you know close to the school but in in
this it's there's way less text right a
lot less text it's clear for each
section what you can do
this is kind of what I'm going for
something more clean it's not gonna be
like this where we just switch back and
forth there is actually not really a lot
of content when I made this the the
hotel wasn't even open yet and there
were no restaurants there so there
wasn't a lot going on so like we don't
even have a tab for dining right now it
was built but we didn't have any
restaurants yet so I'll add that in we
may be actually working on this project
at some point to update it the
restaurant the first restaurants are
supposed to open in October but you know
for instance like the hotel page kind of
a similar thing you can book right away
you know or we can tell you what you
want to see so obviously we want to sell
the Suites right and it's not it the
hotel's run by another company in the
university doesn't directly run it but
we want to showcase the Suites right off
the bat right they're the most expensive
thing we want to sell that then we drop
down to the rooms and at that point we
say hey do you want to you want to book
online now right so you give another
chance
and then we show you know even more
stuff so that's kind of the flow that
I'm going for just kind of like a a more
thought-out approach to if somebody's
coming here what do we want to tell them
and what order do we want to tell them
and then what actions do we want it to
be very easy for them to take you know
what information should be really easy
for them to get to so anyway I know I
went on a lot for that but that's kind
of my my goal for this site now I don't
have full reign over this site you know
being the main site for the university
obviously there's a lot of people that
want to have a say and what goes on here
so I'm gonna try my best and inflate as
much as I can to try to just strip as
much content out of that homepage as I
possibly can I don't care if interior
pages are loaded with content if
somebody clicks to learn more I'll give
them pages of content right because
they've already
the desire they want to learn more so
I'll give them what they want to give
you know a ton of text content but on
the homepage I don't want to flood it
with content you know to everything so
we'll see how much I can I can do here
[Music]
we'll see I actually just had a meeting
with my boss
earlier it was kind of just not really
planned but I showed him what was going
on so far and he shared with me his
vision for the complete redesign when we
completely redo the site you know
hopefully sometime you know next year or
so and it's gonna be very very different
so that's going to be cool I guess just
to give you a small heads up it's gonna
be it's gonna look almost more like a
social media platform than a university
like website users gonna have a lot of
control over what content they see right
off the bat which i think is always good
it's gonna be a lot of base based on
cards and being able to sift through
category content having a really good
search function so it's going to be very
different I'm excited about it it's
definitely going to be react the CMS
will maybe be WordPress unless I can
find something else that I like better
and we'll pull it in through the API I'd
actually really much rather have a graph
QL instead of just a regular REST API
but anyway it'll be really different so
that's the cool project that be looking
forward to and if if Quincy from you
know free cook camp wants me to still
stream at that point when I'm doing this
project then I'll definitely be
streaming it otherwise if I get kicked
off of this channel which I have no
reason to believe that I would but just
in case I think I can always stream it
on my own channel because that'll be a
really cool project alright let me get
an X next question
anyway that was a cool question
Shay thanks thanks for asking that I it
was kind of wide open
it allowed me to talk a lot but I have
thought quite a bit about what I do with
this site I had the chance
okay cool so alright check this out I'm
getting some stuff in the live chat
about how to use Emmet and let's see
oops
dang it I messed it up Wow check that
out that's awesome so it's just made a
ul with five allies and then nested
inside are a tags with the href very
cool very cool so I think basically if
you if you do this
whoops then you can you can nest things
so it's this symbol that's the one is
that the greater than symbol does it
that's really cool wrong it says it's
like a baby getting a new to it yeah for
sure
I'm really excited enough Oh
shaeeah says someone made a simple
Emmett cheat sheet
it's got somebody had to it mate it's
got to be out there somewhere
and John Hanson said if you use pug it's
even easier than those HTML shortcuts
yeah I haven't you well I use try think
well last time I use I did attempt to
use pod but at one point back in the day
it might have still been called Jade at
that point so if you're familiar with
Jade templates plug it plug is Jade they
they just had to change their name
because some company owns the rights to
use the word Jade as their company name
so so they had to change the pug
okay so these so I'm gonna say Zn 4zo I
and IND za since I can't figure out how
to pronounce that so zns can you explain
the master thing alright so these files
that's that r dot master I think now
correct me if I'm wrong for you all that
they know more about this I think these
are like the the asp.net template files
so yes let's see but they are this is
like the top level so anything that's
dot master is like this is the top level
so you can see it has you know the HTML
tag right so everything else all these
other template files these dot aspx
templates they all feed into this one
right so there are actually several
masters but a page can only have one
master file so that's this the top level
little template that would be like the
index dot JSP is or something we get
that would be the page write that in
your page component so that's that's
what master that dot master means in
this context I have no idea if that's
just specific to this content management
system the Ektron CMS or if that's
something that is in all asp.net things
i don't know enough about it to know
whether or not that's the case but
that's basically what the dot master
means as far as I know
Theo says I can't quite understand what
you use a CMS system for in which
situations is it necessary to take
advantage of one is having a database
with the REST API not enough or is it a
totally different thing okay so when I
if I'm developing a small website where
I'm going to be the only one editing it
I don't bother with a CMS I usually only
even bought it with with a database if I
don't need one I just edit you know the
the HTML directly if someone else needs
to edit it I almost always use a CMS of
some sort
usually WordPress because it's it's
pretty user friendly there's a lot of
documentation and tutorials out there
for people learn how to use it because I
can't always be the person that changes
things my day would just be filled up
with changing things on all the
different websites that we have or it's
if it's for a client and it's just a
contract thing and then I won't really
see or talk to them ever again they need
to be able to edit it on their own so
that's why I like a CMS because it
allows them to go in and with the
WYSIWYG editor just kind of be able to
have some control over the content on
their website now if there are
situations where website would be bigger
and I might still be the person that's
going to be doing most of the editing or
other people who maybe know a little bit
more who don't need the WYSIWYG editor
at that point potentially I would want
to maybe just do a database with the
REST API or graph QL or something and
not bother about a full-on
CMS maybe just something really
lightweight maybe even something and
just make you know make myself
so that's kind of it just really depends
on who is going to be doing the updating
of the content and what is their skill
level that's how I determine whether or
not I need a CMS
okay so no beer is giving me some help
in pronouncing ice let me try this
Zillah ninda nimza some saline ins I
feel so silly
alright I'll work on it
okay John B says on the point of the
colors for the footer like the greens
and such why not save them into CSS
variables instead of constantly
remembering the hex values you define
the variables in root then define the
colors with two dashes so main color you
want to call it okay yeah actually I
haven't used the the CSS variable is yet
what's the support for those can I use
them in a in a browser yet so I don't
know if I can then I'll learn how to use
them normally I use sass and I do say
things as sass variables in this case I
I have that green hex color memorized so
I almost always just type it in because
I'm I remember it because I've used it
so often with the other colors though it
would be helpful to just have them saved
in variables so assuming that I can use
the CSS variables and it if it has good
browser coverage then all you know I'll
use them
okay cool so che che says this is a
follow up when che asked earlier about
my plan for the website so here's a
follow up to that
Shay says I like the website plan is the
site more for potential students or
maybe alumni rather than current
students or are you thinking that they
will know to use the menu to navigate to
a student page yeah okay so this is the
really tricky thing the so I mentioned
several times before that I was not
working here when the current website
was designed and developed but I have
heard a lot about the process and one of
the things that happen in the process
which it makes sense that this would
happen is that everybody wanted in on
the website so like the people from
student life wanted a lot of things on
the websites for current students right
certainly the people who are in charge
of getting donations wanted a lot of
stuff on there geared towards donors
people in admissions wanted a lot of
things on there geared towards potential
students and we have other things too
like we put on a lot of conferences for
adults and for youth certainly
conferences one of their stuff on there
and we have like pilgrimages that we
sponsors so people go like you know like
to the holy land or to Rome or something
like that
you know different places and we help
organize those trips they certainly want
so everybody wanted something on there
that's why the current site has so much
on there right every department within
you know that the academic side of
things every department wanted to be on
there so that was really difficult
so what since I since I've got here I've
frequently brought up you know as often
as I can in meetings that we need to
focus on like what is our target
audience I realize we're gonna have a
lot of different people coming to the
site but what do we really want to focus
on and I think we've narrowed it down to
prospective students as our number one
focus and then as our number two focus
close close behind
our donors everything else is is
secondary right so we want to still
provide information about all the other
stuff but that's gonna be secondary so
that's going to be the main focus of the
site so that's why it's it's somewhat
reflected already and I didn't put it in
here but I think I mentioned earlier
this is going to say apply and this is
donate so wait so what happens the main
call-to-action apply and then up here we
have the donate button and then down
farther in the page maybe at the bottom
maybe somewhere in the middle we'll
probably have another at least one other
spot where students can apply or fill
out maybe an inquiry form and let us
know that they're they're thinking about
coming to school here and then you know
throughout we can mention other things
as it comes in I'm you know we'll
certainly probably mentioned some of the
awesome academic programs that we have
going on or like we have a really cool
study abroad program where students go
to Austria and they live in like this I
don't think I think I have a picture
right right here like this isn't a stock
photo these are our students in Austria
and they live back here in this big
building so it's some really old church
with like a monastery type of thing in
the same way with all these mission
trips they take this is actually our
student I assume she's in the nursing
program she has the stethoscope but
there's lots of cool stuff going on that
we're definitely gonna want to put in
there but we don't need to tell the
entire story of what's going on we'll
save that for interior pages so I think
the goal the main goal is gonna be and
this isn't really gonna be fall on me my
boss is probably going to have to do a
lot of the work of convincing people why
we need to build a site this way and
then I'll just provide support as much
as I can probably in the form of a lot
of data that as much data as I can to
show that this will result in you know
more students and more donations but the
main thing is just going to be
fencing you know convincing people to be
on board with this and to not be too
upset about stripping out content
because I imagine there's going to be
people that will be upset you know for
instance you know look at all this
content some people are going to be
upset if they're no longer mentioned
right we have a lot of text here and it
mentions a lot of different programs we
can't keep all of these in here right so
yes whoever's in charge of you know this
particular program are they going to be
upset I maybe I don't know
so anyway if there's going to be a lot
of stuff that's not even necessarily as
anything to do with web development
that's just gonna have to be dealt with
so to answer your question I know I went
you know above and beyond what your
original question was to answer the
question potential students are the main
audience but we're gonna keep in mind
that they're gonna be alumni and and
other donors that are going to be coming
here and we want to give them something
too so we'll definitely want to
highlight for the students in for the
donors we want to highlight some really
awesome stuff that's going on here at
the University so that it would appeal
to both audiences as much as possible
and we already have a site for our
donors a separate site that we can send
them to as well so we don't need to say
everything on this page but maybe just a
little bit and be able to send people to
the right place
let's see and we do already have some
like some web sites that are just like
one-page websites that have information
about a specific program that we send
people to from like Facebook ads and
things like that they go to that one
page thing and it really focuses just on
that particular academic program just
for students who are really interested
in that you know sometimes we'll email
students who said they're interested in
let's say nursing or let's say
counseling because I did a site for the
counseling
they can go right to that site they have
a whole website dedicated just to that
program and then if they want more info
they can come to this site and get pages
and pages of info but we're still gonna
be doing things like that as well and
that takes some of the pressure off of
this main page to not have to cover
everything but yet quite a lot of
discussion and thought has gone into
this already and we're it's been I've
been wanting to redesign this since
before I even got the job here
John Henson says the original homepage
has a 90 style bombardment of too much
content yeah oh yeah I agree I it is is
just way too much
I mean I've I've looked at this web page
for probably hours working here and I
don't think I've ever read everything on
here you know like I don't have any data
on this would probably be cool to get
the data and get a heat map but I would
guess that the percentage of people that
get to this point and the site is
probably in the in the single digits of
you know people that actually scroll all
the way down there I mean especially can
you imagine on a phone how long of a
scroll this is you know we'll shrink
this up I mean this is quite a scroll
and really it's because this text is
just so so tiny it makes it a little bit
better scroll wise but you can't read
that I mean that's that's extremely
small I'm sure it's small for you all
trying to watch on YouTube but even for
me trying to look at it I got to put my
face close to the screen to see that so
I mean I I kind of feel like there's
some shortcuts here in terms of font
size that it shouldn't be like this font
should be at least double the size which
would make this page quite a bit longer
so not only do we need to get rid of
text but we need to increase the font
size for readability like nobody's gonna
you know try to read that I have to try
to zoom in just to see it alright let me
go let me get through some more of these
questions
oh cool Patrick hey Patrick how's it
going
I don't think Patrick did you get here
later what I don't think I've seen you
say anything the whole time but Patrick
came through with a Emmett cheat sheet
so Doc's Emmett do too EMM i ET EMM ET
so Doc's Emmett I owe slash cheat sheet
that's cheat - sheet so check that out
no beer says can anyone suggest to me
how to edit blogger website says please
thanks in advance I've never used
blogger so I don't know I don't really
know how how to edit that if they give
you access to be able to edit the HTML
and CSS and JavaScript I would assume
that would work you know just like any
page but I'm not sure I guess it depends
on what you wish you have access to
okay so Rohan says the next edge release
will have full support for CSS variables
iOS already has it wow that's
interesting I've always had trouble with
with iOS with different things not being
supported so that's that's really
interesting okay I'll have to check
check that out more let's see actually
try right now can I use see if they have
anything
all right so CSS variables obviously in
our Explorer 11 doesn't have that edge
has partial support but it will be nice
chromis
I had no idea that they were this well
supported the last time I last time I
even thought about him I was watching a
talk about them in I guess the talk was
maybe it was a little bit older because
the way they were talking about it was
like no one supports them yet that's
really cool though maybe I have to try
it out okay
hamed says so I'm like a fool beginner
learning Python but I also want to learn
the ropes of web development what
resource should I go to I would say
check out free code camp you know
certainly the the YouTube channel but
also you know free code camp
what is it dot org or we don't word now
I think we are I should know I'm sure
there's a redirect in place as well but
I think it's free code camp org and just
try to go through some of the some of
the lessons probably if you're learning
Python you know a lot of the earliest
stuff will be really easy you'll
probably fly through it but that's a
really good resource it kind of ramps up
gradually unless you know some of the
basics beyond that Udacity has a lot of
free courses for web development most of
them are a little bit get an in depth
more into web development in particular
areas more so than you'd get from free
code camp you know unless you went all
the way through and did some of the
later things in free code camp so if
there's a particular area you really
want to focus on you could just take
that course in Udacity so those those
two resources have been very helpful to
me and I mean there's a lot of other
places for you can do courses code
Academy is I've done a lot of things
from there as well
let's see
Jambi says on browser support of CSS
variables okay so basically just
explaining it basically explaining this
so I didn't see that before I brought
this up so sorry John b-but I mean I
guess this is a decent visual as well so
not bad
J says that was a good answer Jessie
Thanks
oh you're welcome I'm glad you thought
was a good answer thanks for asking the
question and let me gave me an excuse to
explain the grand scheme for the site no
beer says in response to Hamas question
about learning web development it says
one for front-end development learn HTML
CSS JavaScript to build websites to
perfect your skills 3 choose one server
based language for example PHP Python
Ruby for learned a database language
like my sequel or MongoDB yeah I mean
that I mean a very broad plan but that's
basically I mean that's kind of pretty
much how I've been going with that will
yeah if you follow that you I mean you
could be full stack that's you know if
you get through all that Patrick all
Patrick's is without the JavaScript
happy react side I don't have much to
contribute oh I'm sorry sorry faster I
don't you know I kind of wondered when I
would do this if there would be a shift
in the people that wanted to watch so um
there were probably people who watch
because they're very interested in react
or you know at least just JavaScript in
general and then when they saw that I
was doing dotnet stuff they might be
less interested but then there may have
been people who are interested in dotnet
and c-sharp who started watching that
didn't so I've seen I've seen some new
faces and I've seen some people that I
used to see I haven't
is often so that's to be expected and
you know it's not bad I think a lot of
the stuff we're doing now is more
friendly for beginners because we're
really just doing a lot of basic HTML
and CSS at this point and then we're
spending a little bit of time trying to
tie everything into these templates so
it's not bad because you know with the
react stuff sometimes we get in like
really in-depth into things and you know
a lot of the people say wow this is over
my head you know I can't understand it
and so I think it's a good it's a good
mix so we'll be back to react actually
in October so first week of October will
be doing react stuff again we're going
to go back to project one and we're
gonna update it so I'm gonna get a list
of requested updates right at the
beginning of October we're gonna work on
those while we're working on those I
think it's definitely going to be a good
idea to go in try to update our NPM
packages if hopefully we can update and
not mess things up
same thing like new updates on our
server it'd be great to try to refactor
things maybe more testing so we're going
to be back to it but for the rest of
September at least we're probably going
to be working on this site and unless
something else comes up I mean you never
know project one came up out of nowhere
and I had to stop working on this this
site this University site and then flip
right to that project one and I haven't
gotten back to it you know really in
months so anyway we'll get back to it
but Patrick I appreciate all the help
that you've given before I mean you've
given so much help you deserve a rest I
think
okay Jambi confirms it is free code camp
dot org now i dial a I said I'm assuming
that if you took do typing comm it would
just redirect that I mean that seems
like that would be a basic thing so but
I think it's officially dot Ward and not
I don't just think I know it is John B
said it is so it is let's see okay John
Hanson says Google tag manager is a
simple interface to see what visitors
actually click on scroll past or down
how much time or any other interactions
you want to check on okay cool I
actually haven't used Google tag manager
I took a like a course on it and then I
never implemented it on anything so
maybe I'll start using Google tag
manager on some of the newer stuff I
have used hot jar before I think it's
hot jar and they have heat maps of
things so I think that it's I use the
free version I forget what their limits
are so I'm not even sure if it would be
that useful for the amount of traffic
their sites get gets I would probably
hit the limits from really quickly well
Orleans says Firefox as has fonts since
2014 Chrome has since 2016 cool
okay Theo says Theo says in response to
the CMS answer that I gave to to the
question thank you very much for
clearing things up for me for some
reason I thought that WordPress is just
for websites that are made with no
coding but just the visual editor oh
yeah yeah I'm sorry I didn't really
mention that that's like kind of a key a
key thing so I guess most people use
WordPress for that very reason
it's just websites you can get a website
up and you don't have to know code what
we've been using WordPress for and our
projects has been I guess what would
some people call a headless CMS so I
don't worry about any of the templates
that come with WordPress we don't use
them at all
instead I pull all the data that's
entered in through WordPress I pull it
all with an API into a react project you
can pull it into anything I actually
have other sites where I'm pulling it
into just a site that uses some jQuery
and Ajax to to bring in the data but
that's how I've been using WordPress and
that's how I generally do use content
management systems for projects I'm
doing I do have some clients that use
just a basic WordPress site which is
fine for a lot of clients I don't think
they really need a react site I like to
do it I think they end up being a lot
faster if you do it right but I think
WordPress as it normally is used is
still very useful for a lot of for a lot
of people and it can be a very
inexpensive way to get a website up
okay and Theo says I've been using
firebase for my projects lately and that
kind of falls in the middle since it
doesn't require any server-side
programming cool I keep hearing about
firebase I've had people ask me if I use
firebase and think I'm gonna have to
check out firebase more I did I remember
checking it out a while back just kind
of looking at you know what it all what
it was about
and I didn't have time to really
practice it using it but I've so many
people were talking about it to me
lately III definitely need to try it out
okay all right cool so I've gotten to
the bottom of the live chat so that was
a much longer question answer session
than normal but that was it was really
cool it's worth it got some good
questions and hopefully helped helped
you out for those either ask questions
also got to explain my vision for this
website okay I just got another question
pop up here Baaraat says Jesse can you
give some pointers on pulling data from
WordPress yeah so WordPress core now
comes with the API built in so you don't
need you used to need to get a separate
plugin you don't need that anymore so
it's really easy when you're using the
API I I recommend getting some plugins
so check out on the API documentation
page they actually have a list of
plugins that work with the API run
through that list see what things might
be useful for you it really makes
working with the API a lot easier there
are some things that are just they're
just inconvenient to work with so try
out some of the plugins trying to think
what I use now I'm drawing a blank off
and you can check out like project one
has some videos if you see my project
one videos if any of them have that's
WordPress in the title even time you may
be able to see some of the plug
I'm using and how I have it set up but
it'll make getting the data easier and
getting just the data that you want
easier sometimes you may want to get
posts from multiple post types and
there's not an easy way to do that right
off the bat but you can get a plugin
that lets you get multiple post types
you can pull it all in in one API call
and not have to make multiple calls so
that's really useful if you only need
like one piece of data and you don't
want to pull in all this other data that
comes by default there's a plug-in
that'll let you just filter out exactly
what you need so you can make that the
data just really small which doesn't
really make a difference if you're
getting just a few posts but if you're
getting a lot of posts you just pull in
the data you know just that you need so
things like that or be really nice just
make using it a lot easier yeah so just
from memory there's kind of things that
I that have helped me but check out I'm
almost positive that I have some videos
that have WordPress API in the title so
if you can find those hopefully though
they'll help you out as well and if you
have any like specific questions when
you're working with it feel free to ask
them in the live chat or send me a
message on Twitter or some other social
media platform and I'll try to help you
out if I can okay now I'm at the end of
the live chat here again so I'm gonna
finish things up here and I will be back
tomorrow what's what is today alright
tomorrow is Wednesday yeah I'll be back
Wednesday so actually I probably won't
get very much done because my wife has a
doctor's appointment tomorrow morning I
will be home with the kids
I'll come in though into work in the
afternoon most likely unless for some
reason the appointment takes a really
long time but I'll let every
no probably be scheduling the event a
little bit later than normal so I won't
be in so you may not get the alert until
later on or the tweet until later on but
I think I should still be should still
be here and as always if for some reason
I can't stream I put that out on Twitter
just to let you all know but anyway I
will be back tomorrow
most likely around 2 p.m. and I hope you
all have a great day thank you so much
for watching for contributing in the
live chat I really appreciate it and
I'll see everyone tomorrow